[Music]
hey guys it's Justine and we're back
with another MacPro video but this one
is not gonna be anything too crazy in
depth but I just wanted to show you how
I have my setup this is kind of a real
world setup I posted on Instagram and
Twitter it was like an Instagram verse
reality set up and this was the setup
that I showed you guys I have a video
coming out in a few days talking more in
depth about the Mac Pro what I've been
doing with it for the past couple of
weeks showing you a few demo projects
that I've been testing with it just
doing a few simple tasks here on the Mac
Pro big deal oh my gosh they go with
green right now this is just a very
simple desk setup video and the first
thing you'll notice is I have this left
screen turned vertical and this has been
so awesome to edit because I've been
sorting through so much footage hours
and hours of content so many different
multicam clips that I've been working
with I haven't edited with dual monitors
in a long time so this has been such a
treat I can scroll through I can do
playback each clip
I love having this vertical monitor
because I'm able to zoom in to clips and
really get in there I can really
pinpoint pieces that I want out of a
clip and not have to like worry about
throwing it in the timeline and then
being precise I can actually really see
it right here this is also great when I
click over here
my different titles and different
plugins and effects I can see I'm gonna
be so spoiled from editing on this Mac
Pro when I go home for the holidays on
my macbook pro thankfully that 16 inch
retina macbook i guess maybe i have a
little more screen real estate maybe not
this much I decided to put the tower on
the desk because honestly it doesn't
take up as much room as I thought it was
going to and I already have my jellyfish
server on the floor so I think that it
looks really nice up here
I also like having easy access to all
the ports so most of the time when you
plug something in so these top
Thunderbolt ports right here they get
used quite often and then this is the
look that we have
it's a look I think next on my setup I
need to find a really good USB interface
so that I'm able to hook up some cool
speakers if I could control the volume
because right now I've been using
headphones or I've just been using the
speaker that's built into the Mac Pro
not quite ideal and here's why the audio
is coming from one side guys have any
speaker recommendations or audio
interfaces let me know in the comments
below I have a few that I've been
looking at so we'll see if any of your
choices match some of mine this is sort
of a temporary setup since I just
recently did an office tour video my
actual office is right behind this wall
here so I wanted to set this up here
just because it's close to my server and
I still have some projects that are
rendering out on my iMac so I don't want
to completely stop using the iMac until
I have all those files transferred over
and all of those projects closed out so
I think this is just a first look at how
I have my desk set up for the time being
this is how I've been editing all of my
videos and I really wanted to show you
how I'm actually using this and how much
I love this vertical screen I never
thought that this would be the way that
I would do this but the reason that I
did decide to flip it is because I was
sitting like this this is how I said
it's not that great it's very poor
posture so that's that make sure you
guys subscribe because I'll be posting
the video very shortly here doing some
tests with the Mac Pro testing out some
8k footage also rendering a massive 3d
project that would take some computers
several days to do so I'm excited to see
how long it takes this Mac Pro to
complete that project alright that's it
I'm gonna go I'll see you guys later bye
you
[Music]